عدد سوريا لشغله مقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه وحضر الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
قمه تجدده حقا حققت القمه اهدافها طبعا
واجه هذا القرار ردود افعال واسعه واشنطن
كانت ابرز المنتقدين برات ان سوريا لا
تستحق ذلك لكن رغم هذا الانتقاد في العلم
ظاهره تقارير امريكيه وتناولت ما حدث في
الخفاء تسالون امريكيون اجروا محادثات
مباشره مع وفد سوري في العاصمه العمانيه
مسقط ضمت هذه اللقاءات شخصيات امنيه من
البلدين وممثلين عن وزارات الخارجيه
مدى دار في اللقاء اولا ضغط المسؤولون
السوريون بشكل اساسي من اجل الانسحاب
الكامل للقوات الامريكيه في سوريا
وثانيا جدد المبعوث الاميركي التاكيد على
انه لديه معلومات تفيد بان الصحفي
الامريكي اوستن اتايس معتقل في مكان اتابع
للجيش السوري الوفد السوري اصر على انه لا
يمتلك اي معلومات عن الامر لكنه شدد على
ان دمشق مستعده لبذل كل الجهود للكشف عن
مصيره بحسب التقارير الامريكيه الموضوع
الوحيد الذي لم يتم التطرق اليه هو مصير
القوات المدعومه من الولايات المتحده مثل
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لكن لماذا ردت
واشنطن على هذه التقارير
ليس من الممكن ان يؤكد ان كان او لم يكون
اي مفاوضات في عمان وفي اي مكان اخر من
الممكن اؤكد انه نحن نبذل الولايات
المتحده هذه الاداره تبدل كل ما في وسعها
لاعاده الى منزله انا لا اقول ان اي من
هذه هي تفاصيل صحيحه ام لا اذا لديها
الامكانيه لتقوم بمفاوضات حول المواطنين
الامريكيين المعتقلين تعسفيا او مفقودين
بدون اي تعديلات على سياساتنا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات